and welcome to punch-drunk sports where
winner wins
where winners win and thanks to semper
to luxurious perfume subscription
service for supporting punch-drunk
sports go to semper comm slash
punch-drunk use a promo code punch-drunk
for 50% off your first month that's
punch-drunk one word welcome to the show
what a time to be alive you and yours
and me a mine we're great joining us in
studio are all one black guests that we
have on we're really excited to have my
he's one of my favorite people on the
planet every time I see only black
guests I think we have one more Ruben
Paul but is he black Naru is black he's
not from the United States
ok so America doesn't care American
black cream Matthews everybody how are
you yeah I'm good man
oh go ahead we I want them to get your
Instagram cuz you have won the best
Instagram accounts on the Internet I
love it I love ya follow me Kareem dot
Matthews man but don't follow me if
you're super sensitive I do love your
Instagram she gets reported too much
doesn't really you don't walk that line
to two months I know that's what I'm
saying I really could be a lot worse I'm
like guys if you you know I don't think
you push down below I've seen you a lot
worse Instagram account I have yours
always makes me laugh thank you it's
just like people get what's coming to
him in a lot of years I mean yes there's
always like a guy like bouncing another
[ __ ] something you're like oh I know I
know this is cool and totally not cool I
can't watch animals getting eaten that's
how hard thing for me to watch just
going you're like all the fish and then
you just see this giant fish starting to
come up under and you're like I can't
watch I don't mind fish this is dumb
like I here's what I can't watch I can't
watch like you know those videos where
guys will take like no I can watch
hockey sex anybody else can't watch it I
know who can Dwight Howard I can't I
can't you just drop the ones I don't
like are them you know those videos
where it's like a guy and he like takes
a baby by its feet and then like swings
the baby like this and and the baby's
back of his head hits the
table and it's like wow yeah I can't
watch okay watch out the long said okay
that's it I can't watch those even I
know hey um cream where you gonna be I'm
gonna be a flappers tomorrow oh [ __ ]
yeah Sarah are you going to that it
probably won't be there but a little
less
I gotta keep calling it I'm taking a
December off I have some pre bookshelves
those are the only shows I'm doing I'm
taking December off ah but I don't go to
LA I don't go to flappers enough
I like flappers you shut this door all
the time Sam knock it off no but I like
I like I think it's important to get
guys anywhere you can gig and I like
flappers just sometimes you show up and
you're like oh five minutes and you see
who's got like a 15 hour huh are you
like the guy with the puppet soon 15 and
I'm I'm due to type five luckily they
don't um I don't get many of the five
minutes by oh your jeans
you know I like gigging - Sam yeah yeah
yeah that's a good place to go I mean
rich always says come down I just might
my clean [ __ ] is too edgy for that right
and I'm just for a guy who likes to talk
a lot [ __ ] I don't like going into
places feeling handcuffed well no I just
don't like going in and doing the act
that it's gonna just completely piss off
the room I like like the comedy so I go
off and T off and it's fun to watch and
everybody has a great time but I like
going into like somewhere where it's
like this is where clean comedy goes and
as those venues get less and less and
less yeah I just respect the rules
I like that comedy and I'm crazy but oh
you need a venue for that right I
respect the rules about nuts I've always
done that never even early in Vegas when
we're starting we had a rule don't [ __ ]
on the house they're nice enough to last
- stand up
that was literally the only rule we had
don't [ __ ] on the house right now that's
good that's good I mean I feel like I I
try to toe the line
like like with my Instagram but because
I want to be me I want the crowd to get
right who I am right right but you're
right I don't go I don't cross the line
I don't cross I want to get more into
that but Jason where you gonna be
I got a few dates I like to play they
care about them tonight if you're
listening watching this live tonight I'm
gonna be donating sperm into a sock
right around 2:00 a.m. Wow is that gonna
be live I can't be can you if you show
stream next month I'll be spinning a
sign outside of a tire shop hard for
real I met puff-puff gives big heroin
needle roundup working out my new hours
so show up on Smackdown ain't your
needle not often you can hear me work
out some gold and then tomorrow I met my
friend Angela's house oh no surely she
prints her about my gig now after that
friends Oded by a prostitute it's really
funny
next Tuesday is the final comedy chaos
of 2018 Brendan Schaub Eddie Bravo
Brian Cal and Chris D'Elia and it will
grow so I'll come down and grab those
tickets it will sell Oh
December 15th Chicago it is the tinfoil
hat comedy night live at Zanies in
Chicago myself Eddie Bravo Rebecca and
Trevor keV lo will be there dealing rock
and we've already sold a ton of tickets
this show is going to sell out grab your
tickets now grab them now and then guess
what guys hey so listen about twenty
twenty-five thousand sometimes thirty
thousand people listen to this podcast
we've been doing it for seven years
putting it out for you guys ah I have a
special coming that is available right
now it is available on the
okay you just put in go to Vimy LV I am
yo calm I'll put in Sam Tripoli zero Fox
ah the Viper Room any of those it will
come up I would appreciate if you guys
go and check it out it is a dollar 99 to
rent it is $2.99 to buy
if you Brenna can you only watch it once
is that what it means it's good for 72
hours okay that's cool these watches
many times you want and listen man it's
just sports show seven years we've been
doing this boom put it out a little help
when we do these things it helps all to
help us helps this medium girl it helps
like people who want to put out specials
like Netflix is just like now like
everybody thinks Netflix everybody gets
a Netflix special but you'll be amazed
how many people don't guys and it's not
that they're not funny I know what ton
of dudes who rip rooms like yeah they
wouldn't even look at it you know I
didn't even ask him to because I don't
want rules on my special if I could I
would like to put this out at people buy
it
and do it on my own that's what I would
really like to do shove it Sam your
comedy takes so far is sometimes I don't
always agree with you on your comedy
takes there but today you're two for two
yeah thank you it's early over eight the
rest of the way we were normal
oh right for the rest but the point is
is go check it out and see it now
because December 14th is part two which
is Armageddon
okay Armageddon and that's the second
part of special this one is 35 minutes
the other one is 42 minutes and it's
gonna be great man rent them a dollar
ninety-nine help a brother out there
$2.99 to own it yeah you can't really
beat there you can't do it on GP like
for 1099 you get to open up for them
into part three
night of a thousand openers so that's
the business ah cream how are you let's
get into some what do Andy ruther wants
to call it and make a bet with me should
I have him call in what's the bet - bet
is it's about Lakers versus Clippers is
he a Laker guy well he just he's a you
know they're LeBron [ __ ] errs what
is the odd number here Aaron one eight
hundred five five five five five four
five five five
tengo Richter bingo okay text it to me
text it to me before we eat before we
get into that let's talk about this
fight you're at it was great fury and uh
Deontay Wilder so you know thanks our
good friends at CQ go nah didn't I
didn't I watched it though and I saw you
posted Sam man y'all had me so jealous I
wanted to after the winter - you're good
friends at seeking to do seeking
download that go to your App Store and
weather weather whatever phone you got
you download SeatGeek okay use a promo
code punch drunk punch drunk and you get
$20 off your first ticket it's really
easy cuz they list all the all the
tickets available and the base on color
tells you whether it's a good deal or
not
yep so today I saw they go hey tickets
go on sale for Tyson Fury and delante
Wilder I went on the C key gap and I
just started going around and I found
$200 tickets everything was $500 I found
two - $200
tickets and I got it the tickets didn't
move as quick as they want to so they
all ended up being around that at the
end but man it was worth it CGI great I
took a picture of it and it looked like
the the ring was so far away because it
was they were great tickets dude they
were great if you see boxing I'd rather
be higher than like floor level and
lower you're really close no but I was
gonna say when you're really close
though it's a totally different
experience
boxing live boxing on TV I think it's
one of the more drastic differences
absolutely and they may as well you oh
yeah no fine buddy
because you hear that punch hit that bar
um that's I remember mmm sounds like a
drum the provide the first MMA event I
ever went to it was through Rogan cuz me
and a magical were opening forum yeah
and so we were at the Palms and so I was
sitting real close but that was the
first time I ever went to see MMA live
I'm like right outside the cage right in
the super prelims because we got there
like there was a yeah I heard my first
leg kick and I was like oh great but the
thing is you don't hear it on TV but the
thing is that's only one yeah like they
keep taking those but after I heard that
first punch to the body I'm like oh you
take that all night exactly oh that one
right there was like oh yeah punch me
once I would talk about for the rest of
my life there's this time this guy just
punch me ready to rip a jab yeah so so I
go to see geek I get the app I
downloaded the tickets are real easy to
get the guarantee and I think it's
swindle there's no mmm there's no
[ __ ] snow so thank you see geek for
all your sponsorship we really
appreciate it
so um so the day the fight I'm like Dana
you ready she goes for why go to go to
the fight she's like ah oh yeah how'd
you get to go cuz you hit me up last
minute but I was already heard I can't
go I'm like are you really gonna do this
not go to a cuz dude think about this at
that moment of that fight that was the
second best heavyweight fighter boxing
match you could make in the world
right in the world outside of at that
moment
Joshua versus Wilder right this is the
next best I might want to see honestly
this fury vs Joshua before I want to see
Wilder versus watching cuz what you
really were to see what you're gonna see
is Wilder versus Burien and I'm not
against it either my jars for so do by
the way fun
fact the entire night the Intel
including the show the fight that
Showtime showed before it to happen in
Montreal Canada it was all what black
American guy versus a white British dude
it was literally race card the whole
card you mean the whole card a thermal
now in Canada was black Canadian versus
Russian dude so that was but everything
was like that all the way up all the way
and it was and it worked it was right
down the middle dude Oh half black half
British that whole thing and by the way
the British dress to kill we show up in
pajamas right it will see it t-money we
used to be like that so back in the day
now you used to go to baseball games in
suits and [ __ ] oh look at those old
school photos they all crimes and suits
you would walk somebody usually had a
suit on or a barrel there was no middle
of the road no jeans wasn't out yet we
go to fights and like I mean there's so
many good fights dude hurt he's a guy
who had to like the time did you go sit
the gold the gold here yeah dude he gone
black zombie walking with game alright
good oh yeah yeah cuz he just moves
forward and he's taking on this and
here's what I've learned dude he said
black zombie well I do because he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he does back me out
or I'm gonna knock you up that's
everybody watching they make great
fighters they have CTE like at 33 but
they make they dude I have a crippling
drug and alcohol problem we all have you
know you know like free talks about like
how bad it is for these [ __ ] pro
athletes they get into these violent
sports and they're broken look at
comedians they get into this thing they
get drug addiction boom by the time it's
45 for like it's too late for me to do
anything else but it's not quite the
same it is the same dude dude they get
real brain injuries yeah but do you
think I mean listen
whatever you want I mean they make
billions of dollars
no no doubt but I'm just saying they're
probably there other there easier ways
of making millions of dollars like
that's not the way I would want to make
it no cuz that blur that branch if they
go to Israel yeah
but that's why they're angry like that
and that's my thing that's why they
people want them to be cool like when
they get off the field or out the ring
I'm like dude though that's how the
brain is wired now yes Hernandez he had
this [ __ ] yo very bad heard by I watch
this guy file I love watch him cuz he's
just like he walks through punches you
him all you want he just keeps pounding
so this Jarrett heard right so I go they
bring this white boy out of England I go
cuz I end up bringing David dearie
nobody else could make out so sure no
let you but I got two hours before the
fight though I was already I was trying
to find where I must dream this [ __ ] I
was like in the middle of having dinner
with my sister we just ordered food I'm
like on the west side I'm like [ __ ] dude
if you told me two hours earlier I could
have blown this off right now if you had
hit me I would have been down I dude it
was great dude anyways I couldn't
believe he was on the undercard I was so
excited
how many other card fights did you get
to see three two okay so you do and then
the main fight I got to see that awesome
through the guy before who loves his
name who actually fought Garcia no it's
not Garcia Mikey Garcia no the big bald
Cuban guy who fought the fat white guy
ain't just was pounding the [ __ ] out of
him actually lost adelante wild had been
beaten delante wild the entire fight and
then at the end guys while they're just
right he's a one-trick pony
but that's a good-ass trick though yeah
if you have a trick that's a gasser what
a half 45 in 39 naca yeah yeah if all I
can do is knock you out and I'm a bomb
so her goes up and I'm like I go to
David for before the beat okay so we go
here I go this guy is gonna get his ass
beat now I'll tell ya the white guy was
a great boxer right but you tell his
Bhatia technique he had techniques
weights heard head
zombie and i'ma knock you the [ __ ] out
Danny just boom got him in the rib and
hurry did ya her the body boom body blow
guy went up her who's getting beat the
Hulk because that's what her does he
clearly rope-a-dope shoe without trying
to rope a dope you right nah
so then he's doing this so then he's
given us his I did you watching this I
didn't see that fire fight then these
guys broke I mean the Char Char low
brothers CH AR l Oh brothers I've seen
these guys no but I would like to say
this is the first time you not only
pronounced it right you actually spelled
it well I have to do I learned that on
tinfoil hat that I have to [ __ ] I
have to say this these two brothers
right here bro oh wow and they have wild
in their eyes - do you ever see like
when you know it's like when my little
dick down boy I got that Rick Fox crazy
like hey dude I'll fight everybody here
rake the [ __ ] now I may have wild in
their eyes he jumped in I believe it was
him he jumped in to challenge her to a
fight which would be a great fight they
both had the same [ __ ] her obj right
ah so that'd be a great fight to watch
that was fun to watch - yeah then so
then the main event happens right before
does of course they gotta do a moment
for George HW Bush and I heard he's not
dead I heard Elizabeth Hillary Clinton
were just yelling Howard all the [ __ ]
that he did my crack epidemic ah [ __ ]
iran-contra Franklin scandal
assassination of JFK I nobody got mad at
me they were all laughing Wow you put
the assassination of JFK on him too for
sure he's in Dallas oh so what what did
he do with there what'd he do there he
was believed to be one of the three
tramps that they talked about there's
actually a I'll find the Dark Alliance
that breaks down how JFK basely
behind I mean that Bush was a big part
of that and then and then you know
Reagan right you know Reagan Hinckley
Hinckley the Hinckley's were huge huge
they were very close with the bushes
George Bush's brother had dinner with
Inc Lee's father the night before
there's a video that I'm going to eat
together I heard when that happened
Hillary was 11 years old and she was a
finger sticking up for her what you're
doing right now you're mocking people
who [ __ ] say what a [ __ ] evil [ __ ]
she is and you're mocking it he's
mocking it she is that's linking up her
yeah you are her no I'm saying you're
saying what she visit jerk that's what
I'm saying
I'm live into it and then you brought
off the clinched it no I didn't you did
I need to talk about it no you brought
it up so Jared heard so Joe so then the
fight comes [ __ ] you know Wow the
fury comes out to like three techno vers
disco versions of Rihanna like her in
Ariana Grande dancing and then they have
a song there's only one Tyson Fury and
that's the whole arena was singing that
as he was coming out and then how many
national anthems - - they played two and
then delante Wilder came out Beyonce I
think what Deonte came out as a [ __ ]
criminal
weird thing yeah what was that movie
with what was that movie with dark
crystals you guys remember dark crystals
David Bowie was the whole puppet anyways
he comes out and dude I mean I got me
honestly you look at you look at fury
that body is not good it's all he's a
heavyweight right there heavyweight I
mean he's six nine dude and his arms go
forever right punching but they both had
the same reach they both hey no no no no
do they both have 83 it's really well I
don't know what they told you his reach
was but from what I could tell you till
he looked like he had t-rex arms while
they're compared to [ __ ] fury who was
hitting him from the other side of the
ring but see yeah
yeah okay I'm just telling you what the
measurements were it's like when the NBA
players tell here are a couple inches
taller than they are
I'm telling you while I was very amazed
at how much smaller Wilders arms were
then 2 inches shorter yeah I mean dude
and it was a great fight man I was great
I think you want it in a heavyweight
fight who do you think won well here's
why or do you think it's a draw a judge
or if you think it's hard for a fight to
be a draw to me well here's the thing no
fury one in every moment except for two
and those two lost in two points each
time and dude the final one could easily
be knocked out Marlee being called well
I'll be give it gave it this water
thought it with the if that was a UFC
fight they would have just not given it
Wow by the way to a homerun tried while
they went into the homer tried it was
really a double could be a triple if
you'd have been running all right don't
do without I mean fury look out but when
he laughs you're dead I was literally
like oh look like a Rocky movie no
someone was saying that death showed you
that he was awesome [ __ ] you're saying
because you don't get up like that he
didn't even stagger up did the place go
absolutely insane when he stood up yo
bagger up though he just jumped up like
okay everybody there was surrounded by
British guys there's a lot of Brits
there right yeah I mean dude there was I
mean I wouldn't say 50 pay there's
definitely more Americans and British
but they had there yeah there was there
was a lot of British like the crowd was
most rooting for their doing thing about
LA crowds right they are silent until
something happens and then when
something happens at the way all the way
up the way in 90 percent fury in English
fans may be wonderful a feel of the
stadium would have been
my [ __ ] going on nobody going to a
weigh-in yeah friends come and I take
them to games right and they just live
in LA for a day or two and by the time
they get to the game they're like damn
so exhausted it's like yeah welcome to
living in LA we launched a game to relax
you guys go to watch a game to have a
reason to live
you know let's say like in Green Bay the
game Packer game is the only reason you
don't deep throat a shotgun right you're
like [ __ ] la it's like I just wanna zone
out and when some bigger yeah that's
very that's on point right there it's
just the truth dude and then you go to a
Laker game which is even funnier because
everybody's like Laker crowd sucked dude
as a stand-up comic wheat when everyone
goes oats in the industry crowd you know
that crowd Sox that crowd sucks because
they're just too cool for school and
they're just imagine going to a Laker
game where it's not just industry but
it's the bosses of the industry who get
all those lower seats and they're just
sitting there no Tommy's gone thinking
about who what train they're gonna run
on what [ __ ] Laker cheerleader
nothing amazes them but that's I mean
that's LA its but that we shock it's
just we're either Super Bowl or just
tired right from doing so much other
[ __ ] yeah but you know what though the
RAM games have been like real games
they've been getting better rams this
year versus laughing I'm talked about
the all the fans right know this season
has been great yeah fan wise yeah I mean
from the first season come on like the
first season it wasn't even we didn't
even really have real face but like this
year like that Casey game literally the
second half we did not sit down like the
whole second half and asked I mean I was
one of the best it was a Monday night
game right yeah it was one of the best
Monday night games I've seen probably in
20 years do I mean if that's what the
NFL wants right a thousand to a thousand
and one that's why they made the rules
like that
solutely I mean it was it was just up
and down back and forth you know you
knew it was gonna come down to literally
the last play I could see that I mean
like dude if I was the XFL you know what
I do I would get rid of defenses I
wouldn't even have them on the field
what are they starting up they're coming
back when they're playing where that
they're gonna go where the Chargers play
now Oh Steph oh yeah gonna do their team
and I would just get almost like arena
football or even basketball where you
play both sides to play like you throw
pick boom you just form the defense and
then you cover diva and boom you go back
at this point why not I say each team
gets a horse each team gets a horse and
each team gets to plant a landmine
somewhere on this field that the other
team doesn't know that be excited as
[ __ ] I'm gonna have a Luther : I
remember a friend of mine plate in the
XFL the last time she he la team name
they actually won the last championship
okay he was on that team because they
had he hate me too smart
good for him a lot of those guys played
me NFL after for a little bit cuz they
Tommy didn't tommy maddox playing Tommy
Mac says well yeah we did he was around
we drafted well actually no Denver
drafted him but we picked him up after
like his daddy Denver did draft him
that's right it was oh good you guys
think you can beat New Orleans again the
second time if it's at home
I mean that game was pretty much swung
on who was at home I mean I feel like
honestly the same thing with that case a
lot of bad calls that came to and that
KC games same thing like it may have
been different if it was in KC or even
Mexico where it should have been you
know that's why I feel like home feel is
so important for us that we get home
feel and that's back to what we're
saying about the fans yeah the same
record as the Saints right no we have
well they got two losses we got one cuz
they just love right they did lose or
all the buys gone all the bisexuals they
gone
I think this is the last we
by section 17 and 17 and 16 I think are
they I think there's two more weeks of
Oz I think I think it's just 17 and 16
would you rather have the last the later
buys uh
no middle buys yep probably right in the
middle we don't want the early by god no
that's the worst three games in you
gonna buy that just run yeah that's the
worst
unless ours is kind of perfectly time
right after that KC game yeah that's
where you wanna be
we still got five games left you know I
mean but we need to clinch everything we
can clinch though Division home you're
the clinched division right we need
home-field whoa Thanks oh you mean
throughout all the plan oh yeah us in
the Saints then we'll get that first
round bye yeah he's gonna call it now I
mean I just wanted as easy as pie you
know not as easy as possible but I want
us to gather up all the chips we can
gather from having this great season
Colin collards has some very interesting
about the Chargers if they won the Super
Bowl where would they would they have a
parade where would you walk later who
did Haywood where that's happened
downtown nobody would go to it some
people will go if the Chargers won the
Super Bowl they would they would have
fans easy on joining us via the power
strike
from one of the top 47 sports podcast in
America
ah people love it please welcome Andy
Russa from dirty sports how are you dude
Andy ruther who scored a what on the
SATs did you get your score if I
couldn't did you get your score from the
SATs didn't hear you yeah it was I think
I got a 960 mm is that good solid that's
not good that's not solid it's 1500
right he's a white guy he doesn't get
this [ __ ] the diversity [ __ ] him so
964 white
I ain't good it'll get you into college
what college Northridge that's a JUCO my
credit though like you know as it got
taken out at age 36
I didn't bring a calculator I didn't
study I mean no calculator Wow
congratulations I'm not bringing later
so uh we're here with cream Matthews who
if you ever need gas he'd be wonderful
on your show um he's a huge Laker fan so
word is you've been [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
and you wanna make a bet with me what is
your bet well here's the deal Triple E
you know you're so confident on your
Clippers we can go a couple ways with
this one
no way in hell the Clippers go farther
come playoff time then Los Angeles
Lakers who have as you know the greatest
player of all time LeBron James Bobby
here dude
I'm not good discuss a weekend so so we
can go that route or we give you top
three even I have no problem doing
regular-season record the Clippers have
currently the better record than Lakers
by how many games by how many games
right now
oh you come follow me a couple Lakers
are two games out of first in the West
and the Clippers are in first so it's
only two games okay
Clippers got seven losses Lakers got
nine I was just looking at that
yesterday that's clear sorry 16 and 7
Lakers are 14 and 9 so we're two games
back right yep
that this bet is chicken [ __ ] and AH
it's it's it's not really you're not
going out limb you're literally picking
the team that ESPN is in business with
they're in bed with what do you think
that the Lakers why do you think he has
been no longer interviews [ __ ] Alonzo
balls dad because the Lakers told them
if you interview this guy anymore
we're not going to do business with you
they have everything on lockdown why do
you think Steven Naismith just
constantly gets on television and it's
like oh dude those Lakers are go do this
Lakers go do that
cuz they're in badly
meaning they're more likely gonna
facilitate a trade and this has been the
story the Lakers system beat Jerry West
Iran it was playing for them way back
today to force [ __ ] free agents to
this team because it helps the brand so
you going out good I'll do we're gonna
do better than the Clippers isn't really
brave at all you want to give me a
[ __ ] five game or seven game [ __ ]
give them a hundred games give me no I
mean give me a lot [ __ ] a couple
games to do I'll lead I'll do it with
you you want to say hey plus seven you
get seven more games I'll do it with you
well hold on triple you wanna know the
reason I'm saying that is because you're
so confident first of all the disrespect
you have for LeBron James right there is
hilarious that is kind of underlining
everyone's talking about the Lakers
because they have LeBron maybe you
should look up what the Cavs are doing
right now we're out well Oh God
so yeah without Kevin Love firing their
coach it's a completely different team
and I will give you that I thought they
were gonna do way better they completely
collapse now it's not really a
completely different team it's the same
dude they had last year know they
started breaking it up now cuz they're
trash absolutely agree one out freedom
this just shows how great of a player
LeBron is for a mouth you put him on any
team and that team is a cadet team is
probably gonna go to the finals of their
conference I mean they've that's been
the case the last eight years yeah in a
dead-ass listen dude listen listen see
that's the thing then you have to get
into degrading the competition for sure
that's God that becomes the first thing
because I mean I'm you know I'm not a
LeBron fan like that I do
deep throat him constantly how many
times I said I've been all you probably
got me on here hating on LeBron oh and
the Kobe argument from last from last
year but fooling around over Kobe every
time no Kobe's I'm still taking Kobe but
we don't even have to have that argument
right now I'm just saying for where the
NBA is right now but you put LeBron on
any team for sure he's a crawl time
player yes yes I will agree with I mean
look at look at listen you should say
whatever you want
about Toronto this is a better Toronto
team with Kauai than is demar derozan
because Kauai is a top four player
there's five guys that no matter who
they are they're like they're gonna be
good now Anthony Davis seems to be on
the team the one guy that can't lift his
team to Mesa heroic fit LA even though
he's great I mean he's great I mean I
feel like LeBron is really the only dude
why hasn't carried a team to the finals
by himself like quite when dude the last
time the Spurs went to Duncan was not
that great they had point that they per
set him in that last possession I can't
cost him the game I can't put Hawaii in
that category the only other person I
can kind of give that to in the league
right now is Steph that's the only I do
things that I say you think a makes
right and I don't even I can't he I
don't know about KD cuz he's never did
it by himself he had to join those dudes
when he had his chance they blew it
he had a chance to be there I threw it
that's just me so go to gold instead
what do you want to do Luther how many
games you want giving what is it well no
here's the deal strictly because this
whole all let's do seven eight games at
the end of the day that doesn't really
matter what matters is you're you in my
opinion you have you have been
disrespectful again to LeBron and my
thing is at the end of the day all that
matters is playoffs because right right
right
that all matter right all I'm saying is
the Lakers will go farther than the
Clippers that's what I want to bet
that's all this [ __ ] man who will go
farther period what are we betting
period you name it man last time we did
the SAT I took a big al and had to go so
let's say let's say just just sound the
shot shoving anything in my bar today
jerking off the weird [ __ ] let's say
they both go they both get bouncing
around one then and what if they want
one wins two teams one wins one is that
how you would define let's say the
Clippers win two games in the first
round but they lose if you do they both
lose and it's a wash
in mind if they both lose in the same
right yeah okay so it doesn't matter
so 107 games among that swept that
doesn't count right just someone's got
to get to round 2
yeah there would have to be a tiebreaker
in that case Denver's a problem no
they're not and see that's my thing when
you look at that list you look at that
list of teams ahead of the Lakers you
know saying Denver the Clippers who's in
third AC OKC
Golden State they're the only ones like
you what a great first round matchup in
a seer Golden State versus Lakers would
be so happy it's not gonna yeah cuz you
guys would take it to get out of there
it's not no we're going up yo we're
going over the Golden State Warriors
they're going up to yeah I feel like
we're gonna be one two one three when it
all shakes out look in a seven-game
Wataru you got to look at seven-game
series I'm gonna use with you who aren't
Denver who on deeper stays the same as
it is right now Luther I would I'll make
a bet with you if they get some rape
deal that the Lakers are known for and
get Anthony Davis for [ __ ] that maybe
you know to [ __ ] ham sandwiches and
[ __ ] and that's the only what are you
talking about like this this whole thing
if it was rigged that much for the
Lakers it is you look at every trade
that the Lakers have made in the past
they rape trade everyone that's why they
ended it cuz it was a rape trade that's
why they stopped it cuz it was a rape
trade it turned out it wasn't gonna even
be a ranger it was gonna be a what guy
did they trade away and do anything on
that side they're gonna get more what
about Marcus all DeMarco stole trade for
Pau Gasol I mean Marc Gasol hasn't done
jack [ __ ] jack [ __ ] he has he hasn't
been an all-star he's never been to the
finals
everyone neither had power to he came to
the Lakers yeah but dude you put Marc
Gasol a no it was it yes
that [ __ ] second he was a
second-round pick that was thrown in but
turned out to be a grape and then go to
the
go straight concentrate go through all
these magic is a draft pick no they
trade we trade it over the draft but
ahead you don't know who the draft is
gonna end up being though that's like
what y'all did the Raiders with the
Bears you trade and get a pig imagine
that's not a rate trade dude it is a
rape tre okay and and what is your point
like point you know what for the longest
aesthetics do that - you don't say
nothing about they rape trade they got
kg for nothing you'll say Ray Allen for
nothing nobody that's right okay I'm not
saying it's right the two teams have won
more chips rape trade everybody yes
there you go thank you that's not gonna
take down any banner that was my moment
you walk down that wall you having me on
that wall but the banner still have
never seen two people have three
different conversations at once what do
you want to do I don't know what the
[ __ ] anybody's talking about Sam just
won an award apparently he's thanking
everybody at Vicky's roots has been on
hold for 20 minutes and the front ruther
you gotta know the first 10 minutes with
Sam saying you're gonna call soon and we
got to take your call and then we don't
talk to you for 20 ma are we gonna do it
better or not all I'm sayin
I don't need all these little yeah if
they make a right if they make a trade
for a giant player that I want to do it
here's the problem here told you I Kobe
said you hear what Kobe [ __ ] bone State
we're gonna weigh before go know that
Golden State fans Laker fans gonna be
laughing at Golden State fans pretty
soon which means they have something in
the works to get Anthony Davis know to
get KD we're getting both of them but
it's not gonna be here going to them
dude I heard that everybody I'll make
that bet for sure Katie would be the
laughingstock of the NBA if you want to
play with the bra it's just a truth dude
that's how people were bond you're going
to go and stay right
that's AA no I would take that bet but
I'm gonna need odds though that's not a
straight-up bet you'll see goes the
Lakers I you take the best like take the
feel but if I'm aids going to the court
if I make that bet in Vegas right now
they're not giving me straight money if
that comes through that's like saying
LeBron going to the Lakers this time
last year you know saying that was a you
couldn't make that bad that's what I'm
saying but it's not a straight bad it's
not either he's older he does it like I
need I think that needs to be waited
just like you said just like how you
asking him for seven games yeah I want
something I want seven games virgin in
this bet then here's the deal this is
what I'm hearing
if there's any trade whatsoever
the bets off yeah you're saying these
Lakers right here yeah and you want 25
game you want a 25 game and then you'll
make of that but will you give you 25
games he gives you 25 games we can't get
anyone
5 games any trade and no trade first
superstar no Sam
what is the five game what is the five
games matter if we're gonna do because
the five games matter because there's a
an ESPN both wha
but what he's saying wakers but the bet
he wants to make is who gets further in
the playoffs why do you need five games
all they want to make the bet he wants
to make is who in the profile record you
don't need games for that no games right
but if there's a trade the deal's off if
they trade for a big name the deal's off
if they trade for an awful what up to
you what is the Clippers trade for a big
player he can make that rule too but I
make the Lakers because that's just a
bad deal yeah make that deal too if no
if the Clippers can't make a trade
either okay you know no big so an age
this team is compromised any superstar
trade and my team is completed it's a
small trade for an all-star level player
okay so if it's an all-star player but
if we bring in like another Lance
Stephenson then it's not oh no no I can
add we can keep we could have a debate
on whether that is an idol I'm talking
for talk
like Anthony Davis or KD hey do you
happen and do okay it won't be a tre
come as a freak
I think KD comes next year Anthony Davis
would have to be a tree and that's the
only player in the NBA right right this
guy's so competitive
David KD why would he want to go to the
guy that he wants to leapfrog in the
greatest of all time cuz he's gonna take
over for him when he leaves the Lakers
but KD has already shown us he will make
this move he's already shown us that
you're saying no so this is not like oh
does Katie have it in him to do this he
already did this Ruth or you want to do
it or why what do we do Reuther what do
we do what's the map let's do let's well
let's do it and I'm down with that
no trades unless you're saying all stars
somebody of yeah David is talent no no
it doesn't have to be empty Davis talent
has to be an all-star right debatable
Bradley Beal something like that
Jimmy Butler like you know he's not
gonna do it but be here for a guy like
even like what's-his-name from Denver ah
the power forward that's really small
that three note the other guy um that
they signed you know he should be an
ulcer just to make the team but it's
like that level we could have a debate
we could have I'm open to delivered
something like that okay so that is my
opinion
all right Ripley I'm down for it there's
no way the Clippers go farther
especially with your boy doc bumbling
idiot coach in the club I this is a
suicide mission from what is the wager I
don't know what do you want to bet dude
20 bucks
$5,000 how about this you go to a Lakers
game wearing a personalized no means no
Kobe Jersey hmm what about oh there's
another good one
when I got by the jersey no problem yeah
we'll get that man yeah I'm like I'll
pitch it I'll pitch it on that what
about I'll getting that Jersey may if
you're gonna wear it's cool all right
dude all right what about a WNBA game
you die if you lose you God do that yeah
if I lose I gotta go to a Lakers game
wearing a no me no Co features all right
dude that's the bet I'm in love I love
it down that's good that's a good that
bad though I mean if you had to go to
number I want number right I want number
right yeah I hate 24 I like a I like
that if you were yeah that's what it'll
because when he raped that girl which
he's now basically admitted to look at
everything
yeah 570 with Rodney Harrison
Dangerfield no what's the name of the
guy used to play for USC and then he was
Ronnie P rodney peete dude you ever hear
when they talk about um about Kobe like
when you Petro some money who's the best
on radio talk about Kobe and whether he
did or not Rodney Peete goes so nuts on
them that he didn't do it and like they
read the letter and he's like nope I
mean like to the point where I'm like oh
he might swing on them dude like that's
how like intensity is like it's like two
people believe that Rodney that Kobe
didn't rape that girl
Kobe's mom and Rodney Peete that's it
that's it that's it
and now Kobe's not on that list he knows
what he did so that's it that's it
are we good at this official yeah
furthest into the playoffs
loser has to wear and no means no logo
the logo hasn't scored a bucket in 35
yeah but he's put out right in the
brother
hey he's old when's the last time you
done yes going
yeah LeBron is old yeah good point the
logo is old logo is put together every
great team this definitely isn't the
same LeBron but whatever you're sure did
you see that
oh yeah no absolutely the explosiveness
like he can't do it consistently you can
still see flashes you know saying but
everything else about LeBron no one else
in the league has that except maybe
dudes from Golden State there's no one
else in the league I respect to beat a
LeBron team in a seven-game series but
to go and stay warriors Portland did
let's look at those teams no come on the
Clippers Portland's in trouble dude
Denver's not they have a lot of manpower
this Center is great that Center yeah
that was that Center John you [ __ ] yo
got something yoking [ __ ] Watson I
want it all here we go
will you have to play that Center will
Barton great play oh yeah we'll mark oh
yeah dude yeah new part Gary hair skin
score whoo no kick can score joking
yo yeah whatever he's the best player
he's their best player you're taking him
over LeBron can score you taking him
over LeBron James taking him over LeBron
all right you got your bat I love it
ruther book it I think he left Oh Luther
just hung up he that's rude he's banned
[ __ ] that to that okay now we got good
yes who else we want we got a good
friend of ours who wants calling as well
we got [ __ ] zoo man zoo mock about
the Colin and guess what he's probably
gonna talk [ __ ] about LeBron right this
should be the LeBron cast he's if
anybody should sponsor our show it's
[ __ ] LeBron James we have talked
about LeBron James and it's ruther that
always causes it yeah probably 12 hours
this year I mean but well I mean just
LeBron James that's fair yeah
okay I mean who who else would you like
to talk about right yeah I think we
should talk about it more what do you
want to talk about he's a high laughing
right like forever about the NFL all the
time
you have two basketball guys on here no
I'm fine with it I'm probably talking
about LeBron James I mean we could talk
about no we will not talk baseball until
a Braun picks up a bat LeBron picks up a
bat we are all baseball guys listen I
know buddy I was on the Inc might stink
in here from all this LeBron talk but
let me tell you something dude you can
fix that real quick with our good
friends from cent bird that's right try
to set bird service man go to website
cent bird comm backslash punch-drunk
it's real easy dude it's like hey dude
you ever will have a girl walk by you
like damn she smells good perfume
Cologne you name it they have all but to
use any what do you use mostly tears
mostly tears simpered has 450 designer
brands and you choose one every month
Prada Gucci Kate Spade you name it they
got and more that's exact Rai exactly
the brand you want it's a real deal it's
it's kind of like a monthly scent to
venture okay it's real easy that's a
hundred and twenty sprays and you'll
always smell amazing and free shipping
all the time okay skip the department
stores the pushy sales ever seen those
pushy they look good though right those
sales ladies who sell makeup
good-looking yes yeah they're sexy but
you know what I just flashed across her
face when they spray that on me just a
straight backhand oh I don't know about
that and Sanford doesn't know about that
that's why I like Sanford dot-com right
I mean t-bo's had a couple go to semper
dot-com slash punch-drunk and use the
promo code punch-drunk for 50% off
that's s ee2
bird dot-com /pun chunk s-e-c stop
trying to spell it
een t-bird comm /pun shrunk it's real it
works at the word bird / punch-drunk yes
for 50% off yep and they're great
doesn't there they're like pocket-sized
that you could take them with you don't
have to bring a whole giant [ __ ] tub
of Cologne with you so if you want to
take it out and you eat fits in your
pocket and also if you want to try
different colognes you don't have to
spend $150 to buy a bottle of cologne
you wind up not liking you could try it
and put it in your mix up for whatever
you order for the month and then if you
like it make it your new signature scent
also they give you like samples yeah
they're like they're about like a you
know about the size of a roman candle or
something you know I mean like a half of
that I mean I might get you that for
your Holi so you smell good for your
future girlfriend because I think he's
having trouble in paradise over there I
was talking to him before the show and
uh he apparently blames he's like if I
didn't have this dog bro she'd have left
me by now that's what he said you know
that dog dog hey so let me get your take
out Mike McCarthy what's your thoughts
on that
13 years fired in like hey meet me in
the [ __ ] snack room he had to go but
I usually hate with how they did it I
mean you do you let him fly home then
let him go there you lose by 30 they got
a new GM you lose and you're a 13 point
favorite to a to win team at home yo I
feel like you kind of get along if that
is how they wanted to do it to you I'm
not saying that's how I would have done
it but I'm saying you know you didn't
put yourself in a position to make them
not do it another way like if y'all were
fighting you could earn your way to the
end of the season I mean I can't think
that the cards was the writing was on
the wall this law here is last year but
I feel like if the team was fighting for
him then they they would have held on
they would've did it at the end of the
year but
I'm not getting sled them going for game
I'm lying down yes
just let him fly home I mean he's been
with you for 13 years but it's no the
only problem it's no different than
LeBron like how LeBron can fire a coach
that's what Aaron Rodgers did him and
Aaron Rodgers don't get a lot either
I'm not getting and this new teams like
okay we're gonna say four weeks of just
everybody being miserable right now and
it being all the talk because I have
been here in Green Bay fans talk about
this it pretty much all season all
season they wanted him gone from like
but it's also like it gives them an
opportunity to check out their coaching
staff under him you know do we want to
hire somebody within and it gives him an
opportunity to start looking for work
well then it also gives them a jump on
the coaching search absolutely like they
can start getting at these cars because
they they said this started they might
be looking at college coaches they are
they well now that you have these spread
offenses that's coming to the league
right cuz that's what McVeigh did with
the Rams and that's what they're saying
Aaron Rodgers was so innovative do you
so maybe your boy might leach he needs a
running back like my green bay I got the
perfect place for the shitty Aaron
Rodgers need to run a one-trick pony
tail I mean like it always blows my mind
when it's like you need this forever
why I mean you got that right I mean he
has had players though and that's the
thing they always say like you look at
Brady
you know Sam Brady's doing with
receivers you're like who who the [ __ ]
are these receive yeah he does have
grump but Aaron Rodgers has had
receivers he just don't have know right
now but I mean he's got some okay
receivers but he had a backfield Davante
Adams yeah yeah I mean I dunno I would
let him fly home and then let him go and
fire room I feel like would you here
here's your ticket go grab a [ __ ]
American Airlines flight home did they
do grueling like that to where you'd let
Groot and fly back and then they fired
him on the tar kiffin yeah yep and LEM
fly home tiffen did hey they said a push
giving out of an airplane they should
have pushed kiffin out of the airplane I
guy's a bozo hi who's this hey it's true
Marathi check it I got some rumors for
y'all we ate some NFL rumors
okay roomie Noddy let it know break it
down break it down still a couple we
feel Chad the human sumac so that Baker
Mayfield could be a little bit uh on the
queer side I'm going to tell you by
rumor is a hundred percent true I went
to where he went to high school they
County trail high school I talked to a
bunch of people there was a dude that
said yeah they can make some love to be
a power bottom and for those of you that
don't know what a power bottom it it's
what I've got a gay guy struts back in
my your push forward somebody didn't
know what a blow bag was and I felt like
oh dude that's is a UH is just one of
those super horned up dude
I think more these guys go both ways and
you think when you're that full of
testosterone you just want to fall I'm a
hundred percent positive that everybody
in the NFL is a complete [ __ ] okay and
if they want a shot at me come find me
they use the Dwight Howard message to
get away with it they pick up [ __ ]
they have while you play with my blood
you know you're I didn't know I did know
there was a dick on my part I thought it
was a finger I did I know what other
rumours do you have I got one more but
this one I'm still kind of tracking down
this horrible mr. kogo bull hired a new
coach at Jim Boylan they meant to hire
Jim Boylan
but due to a spelling mistake to hire
the wrong one the difference between the
two is an A or an E
so my rumors for y'all spelling can kill
ya those rumors were fire yeah some dumb
girl hi pop - butters yeah now you got
an actor for a head coach well last
thing Tripoli is there at their promo
card for your show a Chicago ah there's
no promo code dude
oh that's happened to me by the way have
you ever seen have you seen that the
Chinese are genetically altering [ __ ]
babies that we both know that means
bigger dicks right bigger dick that's
the first thing they're doing yeah oh
this guy got big old dick that's for
going for that's it yeah that's it so
you're okay with that them letting him
go like that yeah I write or yeah that's
it that's it that's just it
I mean when you a coach you know you're
getting hired to get fired man so we got
a good saying I think was Marv levy said
because you know forever the fans wanted
him wanted them to get a running game
the fans one of them to get more
receivers like they just done them
listen our fan base and Marvel you had a
great saying where it's like if you
don't listen to the fans know if you
lose to the fans you're gonna become a
fan yeah you're gonna be sitting with
them yeah yeah I don't know man I think
rebate needed to make that move and I
feel like when it's to the point where
you're gonna fire somebody however you
want to do it you know I mean it's like
breaking up with somebody yeah there's a
nice way to do it but if it's a breakup
it's a breakup anytime you ever had a
head coach at the pin there for a long
time like a long tenured head coach and
the team sucks for a couple years so you
go alright we're gonna keep the head
coach we're gonna get a new GM there
never were never works that GM comes in
with like I want to fire this coach I
want to get you know our own code and
that's what happened they got a new GM
last year and this guy's like you better
[ __ ] win this year right
I'm here because if you're gonna get
fired as a GM you want to get fired with
your people that you brought in don't
get fired you're firing me I don't feel
like that's the thing about Luke you
know say magic didn't hire Luke all
probably ran trains on Genie I know that
breath I know Jay more was but another
rumor naughty yeah room a naughty why do
I know for a fact Jeanie buss is on HGH
and she sucks off every the Clippers
though that's what's weird but she
[ __ ] a Laker cuz she does like to [ __ ]
where she eat she did penthouse all
right and she takes massive shits his
buddies tried to help I did not do a
video right you saw it was not me he's
cream Matthews different African
American you shake the [ __ ] out of a
woman but supposedly though the video
got well obviously the video got held
this is from February cream was I mean
the Kenzi chief is like let's get a nice
lead with our wins right which i think
is gonna the Kansas he's gonna be in
trouble I mean they played the Raider so
what's interesting is that what's
interesting is that they said buddy say
buddy's favorite twink they said that
they the NFL had tried several times to
get to video but the security people at
the hotel said they will only release
videos to the police how did TMZ get it
right no that's the thing they were
saying the NFL didn't want to get the
video right of course they don't right
then they're gonna force they don't cuz
what was it TMZ the one that broke the
Ray Rice video too
that's what the NFL's doing you wanna
cut this [ __ ] happens
TMZ TMZ is turned into the cops you know
like they broke the Ray Rice [ __ ] yep
they broke this well they started their
own TMZ sports this ah joining us live
via the power Skype out of a third world
country Cleveland
Chad sumac hey Sam how does it feel to
get eliminated by me I'm not eliminating
[ __ ]
I just lost to your dumbass team the
[ __ ] we thought [ __ ] you so hard you
should change your name the Baker
Mayfield that's what you should change
your name to dude
dude people are running with the rumor
you started spreading about Baker
Mayfield dude everybody's talking on now
is that really going around yeah yeah
who was at the room annatee we got a
cease and allowable source your butthole
and his dick that would be pretty
reliable though hey Chad why didn't your
video go viral that video is great that
was like my bill burr moment and only
got three thousand views [ __ ] nobody
cares about Cleveland dude to garbage
[ __ ] you I'm moving to LA and I'm still
gonna represent hardcore Cleveland baby
you're not we're gonna go as far as say
this if there's any fans of ours in
Cleveland that listen to us stop what
you take I know the Lakers with LeBron I
think they're a bunch of misfits he went
there to make movies that team stinks he
doesn't fit with Rondo he's he's hurting
the mone but he did leave all have you
seen there's there are have you seen
their record your record is great
have you seen their record yeah I've
seen their record and what do you think
of it I think they're I mean they've
improved but they're not going to go
they're not going to
do anything we own pace to win 56 games
thank you with 50 games video viral
you have no face so uh so are you guys
gonna have the worst record in the NBA
the Cleveland Cavs
yeah they tanking it was ion what do you
think I like Zion each other I think he
needs to add some more you know skills
to his game I mean we also talked about
18 year old right 1990 right 30 his
explosiveness Joe is something we
haven't seen since LeBron he's the most
explosive dude to come on the scene you
know I'd like the Little League World
Series there's always that warm pity for
a week oh that has a mustache a beard
and he's smoking and he drives himself
to the Little League World Series
but he's also 12 that's what Zion looks
like right and but he's with Coach K you
know saying close case changes turned
his leaf over and now he's grooming
these one and done these last year's one
and dones out of Duke have been pretty
solid all five of their freshmen are
probably in the fourth right got the top
two were to the top two picks two of the
top three cuz there's ball ball dude I
like ball ball
yeah looks like you're like that is an
awkward moving dude he looks I'm not
like a Tim Burton movie but dude
King ball he's 75 with a jumper a
Giudice and he hits it man seven 5:30
spoiler 28 a game man he's like 7-5 7-6
in heels right you know he went to hire
him tomorrow day for a year
oh really who's out here in high school
for a minute yeah he's a basketball
vagabond no he's been all over yeah
that's what they do they just go around
who got cash right now and that's the
thing that's my thing so you know the
FBI got this this whole investigation
going on right right and then then Duke
that's what I'm saying supposedly Zion
was asking teens for cash good housing
good and in jobs for his people and a
spaceship but he goes to Duke for free
yeah
dude you get three on the top right yes
and you but no one's young pay but all
the eleven people all this bigs going
getting paid though John Wooden had that
one dude that ya bought all those
players and he's like I don't want to
know exactly and that's my thing there
John Wooden was a Nazi a lot of people
don't know that it really was was he
with I wasn't what one Chad we're
talking what
Diane's Anfernee Hardaway and blue chips
yeah yeah I got right no I have no
problems with that I'm either they don't
have to change the run either so just
make it legal to Bob what's gonna happen
he's like cuz the NCAA refuses to play
pit play payers which they should to
football and basketball generates so
much money bail out all the other sports
who couldn't exist yeah and what they're
worried about they're like oh if you
started playing these guys all the
females are gonna complain because
they're not getting paid just like the
WNBA look at the WNBA they have the
balls to think they're gonna strike
you're losing you're literally a league
that is meant to lose money hemorrhage
money every year ten mil ten mil mmm and
they wanna raise because that's that's
liberal as this whatever this thing is
it's equal outcome from equal effort and
that's not no no no I feel like it's
based on what your sport is generating
sure if female field hockey was
generating web college football's
generating yes then y'all will be
getting that to horse and the football
players will be like hey we're going on
strike you know what female sport
generates the most money porn okay and
they're well with your higher pay the
men in that field or sure sure base
class the important is the highest
rating female sport let's name the word
let's think about that top 200 female
basketball players of all time this girl
that's play
right now we couldn't dellavedova know
the one that gelatin I don't know what
her name is that's how bad is she Sharla
she just came out you can't already want
a champ that's one so we got 199 more to
go Cheryl Miller Cynthia Cooper Cynthia
Cooper was Miller's sister Reggie
Miller's sister Miller
Pam McGee she was great
Oh Tamika Holsclaw yeah that one black
chick handy Candace Parker
Candace Parker's came like she goes up
is hot I know she has a baby with a to
do from Duke yeah brand magic your mom
was a better player than your dad you
would be the [ __ ] well you know you
remember KD was married - I was married
to a short time to a WNBA player and
though he water I'm like imagine if they
got it right I always wanted to just
kidnap Lisa Leslie and get a jack I make
shaq knock her up and have a nine foot
four kid look at Shaq's kids and his
wife is sure yeah but yeah and that's
why there's six eight dad high school
freshman UCLA but he had a heart thing
yeah he's 611 [ __ ]
Chris Bosh man just that heart just they
won't even let me get on the court
because they're like family signs that
if you die it's not our fault I let him
play and it still doesn't matter if they
sign it cuz if he dies they're still
gonna sue you yeah I'm always like those
waivers that they make you sign at the
park if you hurt your ankle we're not
responsible
yeah I'm still so how about these dudes
you [ __ ] these chicks make them sign a
AA NDA
yeah and then they're like [ __ ] your NDA
I'm right it's coming out anyway right
nah that's my problem dude I don't care
if you're a hooker hook sell the snatch
that's that's capitalism
you gotta have morale [ __ ] ha but you
gotta have morals you should have to
give the money back if you [ __ ] talk
oh [ __ ] Tripp said he gave her a 130
grand to zip it
yeah I don't she's like I'm telling
everybody where people pay hush money
and they don't hush by the way not a
[ __ ] Trump but he's nicer than you don't
think the Clintons would have killed
this chick off or the [ __ ] the
Kennedys duty for the bushes Chinese
will make sure you die by driving the
car off the bridge they're like okay
you're gonna talk okay you can't even
kill a side [ __ ] anymore that's how
[ __ ] up this country I would like to
if you use high [ __ ] Parker do you have
a problem with the side [ __ ] Rae
Carruth just got out who did a podcast
the Charlotte Observer whatever these
papers it's just called Carruth but it's
kind of like a making a murder all about
rape is about him doing it or like the
time he spent all of it from the time
his life the kid wasted his life right
the kid is like special and he was
trying to get custody or at least be in
it now he's like I'll leave him alone
well cuz the mom started bringing the
kid to the jail you don't say cuz the
mom was taking care of the kid you know
so after a while the mom was like no you
gonna be in this kid's life mm-hmm you
ain't got nowhere I'm I'm bringing this
kid up there where are you gonna go oh
I'm not here but he wanted to be in the
kid's life and then they said no you
can't be and then he's like okay well
maybe well maybe as far as custody you
know say maybe he can't get custody cuz
you know his record but they were
bringing the kid up to the jail though
like he didn't you know he's involved
he's involved in the kid's life but the
kid ended up you know the kids had some
learning issues you know
but me you figure the mom dies er me you
would expect something so weird because
so so as a player you marry like super
eye candy but they all [ __ ] strippers
but they don't want to get strippers
pregnant it's just this weird like rule
and it's kind of a joke if you knock up
a stripper they give you a lot of [ __ ]
right welcome so my brother runs strip
bars in in Phoenix Phoenix and he said
that you know he knew players from all
over the place they would just come in
and in this one city two of these
players would just raw dog these
strippers at the club no not the club
they would just roll raw dog sentence
that's what you take but you know again
these dudes got the herp though like if
you look up who has the herp that list
will blow your fearless oh and it will
blow your mind yo you'd be like no I've
heard a handful of ones that shocked me
I mean like the Clintons yeah you're
surprised by that I mean kinda I mean
not really but yes yeah I mean when you
think about annek pedophiles you don't
think you get the hurt now I know you do
you're saying but you look that list up
your little [ __ ] you up
but that's why I'm is the really nobody
you can you're me like you a dog needs
to just be out being a herp so you
Dodgers fan hell yeah I bleed - are you
happy they refined Roberts yep yes yes
he's gotten us to the well I mean we
hadn't even been to the World Series in
30 years we've had this either the
highest payroll or the second highest
payroll but I don't feel like even with
the high payroll I don't like how the
rosters constructed like I don't like
all these platoon players I feel like we
need him did not it's not him that's the
general manager yeah and they're the
ones that they basically tell him how to
manage most teams have about ten and a
link guys who could the Dodgers have won
mmm no I don't they play too much
analytic in everything their play date I
agree
play on this team Babe Ruth will be a
platoon player yeah they were platoon
Babe Ruth against Lefty you want to win
a championship and you can't tell me who
you're starting first baseman is and
that's my thing we need more stars we
need more players than you they don't
play them by God in baseball that sucks
challenger hasn't the Yankees still do
it the Yankees own platoon a guy Stanton
judge that's what and that's what we
need
but Bellinger has I think we might be
gone I think they might move use him to
make a chump you see that but like we
have to rip something out of him no let
her lick his bat somewhere else
we had Turner and Machado there you
would be like these are not platoon
players everyone they were the Turner
and my child were the only two that
weren't platoon that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying we had the will
we had two guy that you would say these
are platoon players I think we need to
get more guys like that that you're like
these players play every day I freeze
who was like a [ __ ] could hit all
done he falls in the platoon category
because he's older he can't play and I
think I don't want him he's gonna make
and he would be an everyday player but I
don't like his style of play he's like
we don't need a left-hander we don't we
we're stacked with lefties the dude like
Harper we need to try to get his Mike
Trout he'll never give him up he's the
only reason they go there who goes there
I think the angels are gonna make we
need to we need to hook the angels up
with a nice ass package of players to
rebuild cuz you're not going nowhere
we're [ __ ] trout yo y'all you have
tried that here are some nice young
pieces to start you know a lot of those
yes
our field her to take Verdugo you're
like for juegos hey have him y'all want
some young pitchers table even they go
URI it take plague you know you're weak
what else do I want would have would see
we can put together a nice package
LeBron well y'all to start over
give him a brawn and y'all will be as
good
I go walking people fit him perfect he's
right-handed yeah in the middle auto
left-handed bad guy why he would start
in center field
we could put on him other [ __ ] around
him yeah let's go to baseball guy with
your thoughts
Aaron well I don't I don't think angels
are gonna give trout up particularly to
the Dodgers I think he's going to Philly
if anything they're gonna save up
that's his hometown that's where he
wants to be so ya know I feel he has
feeling to make a break on the air and
after that he Harper is a good move for
you guys I don't think so you don't
think another 30 home runs a year but he
hits 220 like we have a money this year
but he's not generally at 220 he doesn't
excite me we're gonna pay him so much
money right and then contract is gonna
be an albatross in Chicago
I don't want to move it I mean I I want
pictures I want pictures me cago is
where I thought he was going in the
offseason I want pictures to a couple
starters and somebody else for the pan
your closer has heart surgery yeah and
you're not doing nothing to help that
out like that's nothing you're just
barely back from Arthur he's not but I
mean you baseball players not like heart
surgery to an MD right yeah no totally
and that's my thing I don't say get rid
of Janssen cuz get rid of them for who
like Chapman is really like the only
other closer again not comparing him to
LeBron but he has World Series
experience so you can't just go pick out
your home runs up you can't go just pick
up and closer from the Mariners yeah and
be like okay you're gonna take over well
let's go get the D rays closer yeah
he'll be he'll be better or the or the
dude from the race tell me this [ __ ]
farm system we have that supposed to be
dyno my is does have one guy that can
hurl I mean
Buhler like you learn for a long time I
would like to put Bueller in the bullpen
he's gonna be more valuable there but
then he shows [ __ ] I'm just as valuable
as a starter dude but you know our
barbam farm system is always over hide
yo that's how we do it don't yield on
all these guys we think you did it dude
what's his face Verlander I know I know
we wouldn't get the urea
Fernanda would have won that world urea
sand [ __ ] fur dude nah
you're done dude Verlander would have
won us that World Series cuz we would
have had him and the Astros would not
have handed if those [ __ ] would have
played woods even this year when Woods
was struggling when we played against
Houston what's the only one that shut
him down
he has their number if they would have
played started the game what would Game
seven Game seven
we would add a championship but because
these ass they do it every year later
two years in a row they butt [ __ ] us
with [ __ ] analytics game analytics is
ruining baseball I'll tell you why
because once you start playing in games
analytics you [ __ ] the stats up
they're not natural stats their
analytics their in-game analytics data
I mean you've affected the numbers by
playing a certain way so of course they
go one way and the other
they're not natural stats in game
analytics are garbage Analects are great
for Who am I gonna dress Who am I gonna
sign that's great after that every
single World Series since they started
doing in game of Analects has been won
by a guy that is an old-school feel it
out player am I wrong manager only thing
that analytics does that for the Dodgers
and the did the dudes the doctors have
running the team right now before when
they were in Tampa Bay and now what they
do these analytics fine or like players
who are marginal dudes with other teams
that become side down no like Taylor no
right right turn or Taylor Muncie they
are signing these deaths great so that
was only one thing that's the one
analytics does that I like but as far as
once the game is going on I'm not a fan
of it at all ditto do you remember when
we put like 21 or 23 on Milwaukee do you
remember that game did not seem none of
those dudes who hit thought I batted
right and you can't get in a rhythm
right it's not good it is my opinion
that baseball is [ __ ] scared of these
salaries that are skyrocketing so
they're trying to make everybody a
platoon dude yeah I don't like that
especially for the Dodgers we spending
all this goddamn money we should have a
lineup of players that are everyday
players like you said we got the first
or second highest payroll the Yankees
are probably first or second but they
got a do that everything was number one
oh my god what the Giants were number
one last year what yes Wow garbage yeah
but like the Red Sox and Yankees both
they don't really do that platoon [ __ ]
they got five four or five or they ate
starter that you know these dudes play
every day and you know who the [ __ ] they
are that's how I did a little platoon at
first base and catch her but yeah that's
what I'm saying like four or five of the
eight you know I mean like for us it's
like six of the eight or platoon died
literally Machado and Turner
we're the only dudes that did in platoon
yeah like for me your corner dudes
the corner spots first third left and
right those need to be you know saying
bona fide dudes like those positions you
want to put tuna second and short
catcher centerfield okay but your first
baseman third baseman left field or
right fielder need to be black dude
there's never been a team that's gonna
great series where I don't know who the
starting first baseman is right no
that's real or third one now Union or
through see all fielder's well I don't
know who the started yeah right yeah and
listen dude sometimes too much depth can
hurt your team no it's good for the
regular season but in the playoffs you
need to know who the dudes are gonna be
and that's back to my LeBron argument
like these other teams with already you
know I got eight good guys yeah that's
cool
comes down to the boss well if the win a
championship I say three things you need
ah
you need a franchise player and not
every all-stars a franchise player
there's very few franchise players
absolutely I mean look at the difference
in Toronto this year versus Toronto last
year
tomorrow DeRozan versus quite Leonard
but it's different right but it's not we
haven't seen the difference yet though
because they weren't winning regular
season games with those dudes right
we've got the difference it's gonna be
but they weren't very to the Western
Conference and whooping that ass yeah
but they still will disagree on that but
that's Moe you got your three all-stars
you got your three all-stars you have
three also loved not necessarily make
the all-star team but could easily be an
all-star and then you need a
sharpshooter and sometimes you get all
those in one player Kobe Cady Steph
Curry you get all those in one player
you know but if you don't have like the
Clippers have a [ __ ] assassin they
excited to assassins Lou Williams Lou
Williams is killing it and Gallinari is
hitting everything and then you have
your nice we don't have a franchise guy
to me luhan's yeah he's a proven
non-winner
like he's never ham and crosses bombs
wrong he's always hears me but there's a
reason for that because he's throw-in to
get a good get back get that also you
like will throw you Lou willing because
guys super one-dimension I've been
watching him so I watch every day when
they were going to garbage time and
that's the kind of dude he is he's a
great guy on a knock good team he's
never gonna disagree on that again okay
so that's fair so the numbers say this
not a later than the Lakers have this
has been baseball somehow we switched it
back to basketball and Lakers and
Clippers again no baseball let's talk
baseball Dodgers we serve I haven't done
anything that's awesome dude
I mean like do you two characters we
need to catch her eye I do Dave Dave I
know David Roberts is a nice guy too
good dude I know that he he's not making
the call but whatever's going on I'm not
gonna invest in this thing I'm just not
dude when they didn't play Bellinger
gave one I literally
like I'm out dude I'm not gonna
emotionally invest in this I don't care
if they win or lose cuz you're not
feeling the best team
you're not tell me your analytics worked
cuz you got house I don't matter
I'm not mad yet at Bellinger being
platoon like he hasn't proven to me yet
no he did what you should have won huh
you know 100% been in there I think Kemp
should have been starting can't became
his left-handed starter left-handed
pitchers can't eat Sam up if he stars
Bellinger can't play first this month I
get it
months he's great bring him off in the
later one to hit a home run that's
really what months he is well he might
are shaming homers yeah but dude I
already hit K Morgan MVP better here 240
okay that means a lot of times he's not
hitting ride the guys have got you there
no I feel that I feel like I feel that
you gotta go with the hot dudes but I'm
just saying we had too many dudes that
felt like they should be playing dude
you're not supposed to have that many
dudes that say hey read this as good as
this guy he hits 250 I had 255 now you
didn't have shoes that are hitting 320
no one says that's a turner no one said
that to Machado because their numbers
were superior than these other dudes you
bring in three dudes that hit 250 they
all want to be out to here right right
saying Kemp Kemp was cool but you know
he was gonna break down like I was happy
for whatever juice he's using wasn't all
right you can't do it man let me ask you
something can I switch it to another
gear tumbler you guys ever go on tumblr
tumblr is now getting rid of all their
porn all their eights like this they
just put out the suicide no which was
like we're getting rid of pool yeah Dom
blurr is done I know oh oh dude you can
go see any kind of porn I like it was
where like you could find your community
we're dis right whatever you were into
the community of weirdness was there and
uh got rid of it it's gone he said they
put out this suicide suicide you
remember when the Instagram put out like
we have the right to use any of your
pictures and Kim Kardashian's like guess
who's leaving Instagram and his grabs
like okay okay what I don't have yeah
you know the right so the get rid
because I guess there was some illegal
[ __ ] was popping up on there so and I
respect that on tumblr yeah so I respect
them getting rid of that but dude you're
literally so ruining why people go
nobody's going to see your blog's
because what you are tumblr is just
Instagram at this point you get rid of
all that your Instagram you go to tumblr
to see the weird [ __ ] right no that was
a thing go see all the weird it whatever
you're into there are [ __ ] blogs and
blogs and blogs into it mmm I see you
worthy where will we go on the internet
to find our corner I know right where we
going the internet to find our Pole oh I
guess my own get something back to
MySpace haha I guess I'm pected by a
magazine do you know why my spirit died
cuz dank it live
no because the CIA I knew it I was gonna
say if this gets to the Clintons I'm
gonna be shocked or the CIA CIA wanted
the data and he they wouldn't give it to
him and sell Tom had morals Tom did have
morals so I'm used to come up to
Dublin's oh yeah oh what a wonderful
time of that was this is a great time
for comedy to know it is like it is I
believe political correctness is just
some [ __ ] PSYOP that happens in the
media and social media when you if you
go to a certain place like if you're a
comic and you play a college gig you
better be squeaky clean yeah and these
college kids who think they're trying to
make a difference in the community by
getting rid of like mean jokes hey
you hate guns too right you want
everybody but yeah you go see movies
have guns everywhere
television shows have guns everywhere
yet you're not trying to get rid of that
cuz you're [ __ ] in a hypnotized into
acting like take it away you know
politically incorrect jokes are gonna
make the world a better place
I think every baby should be born with a
gun I think everybody should get a gun
they should they should I agree oh [ __ ]
that baby yeah baby
it should just be like the Wild West
like you should be able to shoot anybody
you want any time that's actually show
right oh yeah
statistics actually show and you can
make a bet on this with if you want with
me and you just gotta go to bet DSi bet
DSi for all your betting needs gonna bet
the açaí use the promo code punch 25
that's right and you get what chase 25
$3 to gamble with they've been around
for over 20 years and you can pretty
much bet anything you bet on politics
you can bet on UFC 231 when's that
Saturday and what are the fights
that's max Holloway and Brian Ortega and
then you have Valentina Shevchenko
versus Tony inch cliff yeah Tony hits
close fighting dude
Izzy never seen that they say they're in
the same picture by see Photoshop but
that's just that's Photoshop hundred
Senate they've never been in the same
place every time she fights and Tony's
at the fight notice you don't see him in
his seat when she's fighting so yeah go
to Betty si.com
use code punch 25 that get you 25 $3 to
gamble with and whatever you put in up
to I believe huh two hundred dollars so
what is the amount up to five hundred up
to five hundred they'll double so BAM
breathy sigh for all what about their
absolutely great get the app a lot of
prop bets going around and if their
horses on there you bet everything
whether you bet on politics you can bet
on an email sports like lesbian porn you
can bet on reality shows you can bet on
reality shows
yeah use Yahoo punch money fibro that's
25 bucks together game Kilian purse like
you get a million dollars at the [ __ ]
lake killer [ __ ] sobbing huh how's the
guest list for your show oh I'll put on
is the Asian all of a sudden is that
Bobby Lee is that or
I'll put some fighters on there on what
on my guest list for my show it depends
on the show like last time yeah yeah
okay I thought you were depending on the
show if it's like a monster show the
[ __ ] guest list just goes off the
[ __ ] rails he posted all of his like
a bets that he made this guy Gamble's a
lot Rosie where sometimes I mean he'll
always you never can tell I mean I kind
of I was up but then I was down and
basically even this guy's always even a
gambler will never tell you never get a
straight answer I'm basically even that
means he's losing oh that's my dad right
my dad my dad calls me from the office
which is whatever Indian casino he's
gambling at all right I'm like that
where are you the office right so he
goes did a Turkish and dude like we'll
go we'll spend some time together in
Vegas Vegas right and I'll go and I'll
watch him lose ten hands and Rob and
I'll be like dad how you doing I'm even
but I just saw you lose that's ten hand
are you gambler yes what do you like to
play our best sports but when I'm in a
casino
I play craps and blackjack you know same
but the best but it's scary it's like
this though right oh yeah I do but I
love it I play blackjack for this me too
you can sit at a blackjack table for
hours and actually be even you can't do
that at a crap table you if you're at
crap table for our I told you there was
a job where you could make $70 an hour
you'd be all over it that's blackjack
right people it's so greedy and try to
be like I'm trying to come up no no no
you can have a dollar you know my
girlfriend does I didn't she goes and
Gamble's right she'll get up $1500 and
leave no uh-huh and give it all back and
I just like you know [ __ ] that yeah dude
I mean when you got a when you get a was
he always gets up to she's good at
getting well it depends
what you're dealing thing is like if she
if she's won like 50 G's before then
it'd hurt mine 1,500 it's just on the
way yeah you don't saying but if 1500 is
what you're trying to win you got to get
away and go put that do something with
that yeah dude just pull it put any back
take another hundred bucks get away with
that
yeah that's on plane if I lose I lose
this $50 and I'm telling you she does is
every time like she could she could make
money off this she's never left with the
15 no yeah she's coming if that's her
thing then 1,500 is just on the way if
you went 20 if you know dude I don't
care unless you live 5,000 before you
got it past 1,500 to get there you know
you're gonna kind of do that all you
want to win is 1,500 1,500 but if you've
won 25,000 you're gonna put that my boy
just want 10 G's I know betting games yo
I was like I've never hit like that
that's a nice lick I don't give a [ __ ]
how much you play I think Gabe just came
up with about 5 mm I mean according to
his III gamble too emotionally when it
comes to betting on stuff like I bet on
people I like more than who I think
might wanna fight I love parlors I love
great mom needs you to be betting
three-team parlays if you hitting 4 out
of 5
cuz you hit a three team parlay you're
not gonna be mad it doesn't pay as much
as a five team parlay they hit as much
did the craziest one oh you said that's
the thing yeah you just want to roll it
you just want going go for the nod man
shooting guy stuff all day no that's
still I like to take the dice that
somebody's thrown [ __ ] just throw it at
them
yeah I like shooting mmm
not not as much as I was like Vegas why
don't you biggis more I would love to
all right you just got back from
Christine some casinos in New Mexico
last week
and that you like doing the road yes I
want to do it a lot more yeah it's just
good to get out just [ __ ] shake and
you realize good to get out of town
about saying you realize the difference
of LA you know I'm saying cuz I grew up
here so it's like when I get to go to
these places it's kind of oh we come
back you know saying your batteries
recharged yeah and just like it they're
so thankful not like here everybody's in
the industry a ting like oh you're not
you're not [ __ ] ever CEO Vegas
vacation Terry chase Vegas vacation and
they were in Vegas like that like a
couple days too long you know when
you're in Vegas for like six days you
start to [ __ ] go right you start to
think things are real that aren't real
that's how LA I don't know what you're
doing that's how that was like math in
those casinos though there's no clocks
all day this is not normal [ __ ] going
yeah but they were there long enough to
that became normal LA and performing and
doing the performing here can be like
that too like if you just get to this
weird zone you're like oh you're broken
and bill burns to power on every show
you how it is right now then you go to
like a normal town you I won't kill
myself
nah so true man so true I will [ __ ]
around some cuisine dude I like doing it
I'm I want to do a giant show I did I
love vinyl you ever been the heart or
the hard rock oh yeah oh oh oh yeah yeah
that's what you want have a special I I
wouldn't mind shooting special there I
don't know if I have the file I think I
could pack it I think but then you'd
have to pack it twice to shoot it twice
right you know that's the only thing
yeah you know I like doing it the Viper
Room check out my special zero Fox on
Vimeo I like because I knew I could put
300 people I just had to do two shows of
like 120 you know
right I'm like one of the weird ones
we're like I know I could do really well
in LA like I've been playing here so
well people like I want to do my special
Nelly I'm like no I have a following
here yeah no you've cultivated that Sam
yeah so it's like I like I'm very happy
with the special you know I get mad when
people are like oh dude who's good at
bein efflux no dude it's not true it's
like dude you're either it's some shitty
specialist on Netflix if you ever try to
watch any of the foreign language
stand-up specials on Netflix oh just to
kind of get the vibe of it it's weird
it's hard your ears stand up as an
American craft you don't think like it's
like jazz like it was it was created
here so it's translates totally
different overseas oh yeah
it's you know it's funny because we have
a do Rafi on our comics basketball team
who's like huge in Brazil but he's out
here now and he you know he's funny but
definitely the translation transdude1996
and
he just like I'll show you you wanna see
how it's done he goes up there just boom
powerhouse is that right right now yeah
I want to go to England to do stand-up
but word is like racial comedy doesn't
do and I like Iraq everybody I want to
talk mad [ __ ] mmm they say versa comedy
doesn't play well yeah yeah yeah I mean
America we constantly inundated with
diversity so everybody talks about it
you know like what do you think a comedy
right now as we wrap it up in LA I think
it's I think comedy right now in LA
there's some great people I think it's
such cookie cutter [ __ ] now like I know
everybody's act as they're walking to
the stage it's like so on and like
everything's just like you're not really
trying to be a great comic you're just
trying to do something that interest
suits at this point interesting yeah no
I mean I feel like there's always that
element there though you know I mean and
that's why when you were talking about
your theory on comedy earlier I was so
with that because that's kind of where
my mindset is right now it's like about
[ __ ] Netflix we're not [ __ ] it flicks
but you know I'm saying I want you
wanted to have your own control of your
special and then also how you said about
the rooms how you know what you do
and so you have your own space for that
like you're not gonna sit on a room but
you know this is my style and I think
that's what makes you different that's
kind of what you're saying people aren't
doing right yeah well dude and we all
wrap it up I'm telling you doing your
own special is going to be the new baby
podcasting no I mean that's why I'm with
that cuz that's what I'm that's the
route I'm about to take I'm telling you
man I'm gonna do my own [ __ ] and do what
and put it out you put it you try to
make it as much your money back and then
hopefully people will find it but at the
end of the day dude it's like you want
Comedy Central did to comedians which
was ice everybody out except for this
one group of dorks which created the
entire podcasting world now Rogen and
all these guys were able to do their own
thing and they were still attacks as
everything but the majority of these
people did podcasting did podcast
because the industry wouldn't give them
any opportunity they had to find the
fame and now it is the standard and
radio
dying cuz people is already are like oh
that's so corporate crap it's not real
right that's what's gonna happen
specials cuz you're gonna see Rogen's
great maybe it's Tom Segura who's
[ __ ] great and can get away with
saying some pretty edgy [ __ ] but for the
most part the people they are letting
through our very corporate acts and
people are gonna be like garbage I'm
loosing this and it's [ __ ] ten times
better than that why is he on there oh
yeah because you're not letting them
play no you know I'm not gonna fight
that Sam I'm telling you dude you're on
why you should get a podcast you're
[ __ ] funny no I have one they I need
to find a good partner anybody wants to
partner up how that mean I will figure
it out yeah that's the thing I'm totally
damn block might be good for you
I need someone sumac sumac final
thoughts Jason uh I love LeBron James
I'm with that too go Lakers good good